euh est-ce qu'on y voit un peu plus
clair Bruno fou pas vraiment on est dans
le début d'un processus donc attendez
une semaine les choses discutent je me
souviens qu'à il y a quelques semaines
nous avions évoqué cette question sur ce
plateau et je vous avais dit déjà que
attaquer la question de la réforme par
l'âge pivot de 65 ans était pas une
bonne façon d'approcher la question et
que la question était un il faut
travailler plus ça tout le monde le sait
parce qu'il faut équilibrer mais deux
que cette réforme doit être juste et
quand vous avez une réflexion qui a été
menée depuis plusieurs semaines
notamment au sein de la majorité en
disant qu'il faut que la réforme soit
juste apparaisse comme juste et soit
juste et bien dans ce cas là vous
trouvez d'autres moyens d'autres
méthodes aujourd'hui la réforme Touraine
c'est quand même 43 ans de cotisations
un jeune qui rentre sur le marché en
moyenne aujourd'hui il rentre sur le
marché à près de 23 ans 22 ans et
quelques mois et 9 mois dans près de 23
ans 23 ans et 43 ans un jeune qui
démarre aujourd'hui il travaillera
jusqu'à 66 ans donc il faut quand même
voir les Juifs tels qui sont et il y a
pas de là on peut dire 60 ans c'est une
escroquerie parler de 60 ans aujourd'hui
parce que dans la réalité ce ne sera pas
le cas
aujourd'hui
on passe à 40 annuités c'est notre
histoire oui mais ça on sait très bien
que le modèle de diaphas déjà là il est
déficitaire alors donc et c'est là que
je reviens à mon point de départ c'est
qu'il faut que la réforme soit juste
c'est que réformes elle doit être juste
elle doit également apparaître comme
juste pour les personnes qui commencent
beaucoup plus tôt les personnes connaît
les pieds pénibles les aides-soignantes
par exemple qui travaillent de nuit
voilà travailler qu'on allait être
soignante travaillant de nuit jusqu'à
65 ans donc il faut que ce soit juste et
qu'on intègre donc dans la réflexion un
certain nombre de situations de
pénibilité de carrière
écourter fragmenté des femmes qui ont eu
des enfants qui changent de travail il
faut qu'elle soit juste voilà mais donc
on travaillera plus ça c'est une
évidence et tout le monde le sait dès
aujourd'hui avec la loi Touraine qui
rentre progressivement en application
Agnès le texte sera présenté en Conseil
des ministres le 23 absolument janvier
et début de l'examen la semaine
nationale en février bon vous êtes prêts
pour la bataille non mais c'est pas une
bataille
ça ça va être une bataille non mais ça
va être ça va être un débat animé mais
c'est pas une bataille dire les choses
sont sont claires vous avez en 2014 un
gouvernement socialiste qui a voté une
loi Touraine qui va en 2035 dire que en
France il faut cotiser 172 trimestres en
43 ans donc tous les gouvernements quand
ils sont au pouvoir vous disent il faut
travailler plus c'est une évidence parce
que vous l'avez expliqué tout le monde
le sait aujourd'hui et quand ils sont
dans l'opposition ils font mine de pas
s'en construire le PS par exemple avait
62 ans de programme lorsque c'était un
Hidalgo qui était candidate élection
présidentielle maintenant c'est 60 ans
donc on voit bien que c'est ça n'a pas
de sens c'est de que des arguments
politiciens sur le travail des seigneurs
bien sûr qu'il faut travailler avec
aujourd'hui le travail des seniors la
jamais été aussi importante en tout cas
la progression a travaillé des seniors
depuis 2017 ça ne cesse d'augmenter donc
on travaille là-dessus mais ce n'est pas
la hauteur des enjeux il faut travailler
ce point-là bien sûr mais ce n'est pas
la hauteur des enjeux financiers ensuite
bien sûr même si on avait 15 milliards
c'est prévu en 2030 de déficit le corps
du 15 milliards de déficites on peut
financer c'est pas compliqué de financer
mais ce financement là il va être on va
en avoir besoin pour financer la la
question écologique pour financer la
souveraineté industrielle pour investir
dans les nouvelles technologies donc cet
argent là si vous ne le mettez pas si
vous travaillez pas suffisamment vous
mettez dans les retraites et bien il va
me manquer pour la cohésion sociale pour
l'éducation pour le travail sur sur
l'emploi et donc on a besoin de
d'investir également dans les forces de
police dans la sécurité etc donc tout ça
c'est du budget dont on a besoin donc il
faut travailler plus et je le répète de
façon juste à ne pas on arrive
maintenant à un point d'équilibre
quand on leur dit ça va être 65 ans
c'est à court terme il y a deux choses
il faut foncer chez les Allemands les
secouer pour qu'ils acceptent de
modifier les règles de prix de
l'électricité parce que ça c'est la clé
on a tendance
à voter pour que tous les états sortent
du traité sur l'électricité pour le coup
là il faudrait que la Commission
on peut pas
d'accord mais
structuration du du réseau électrique
qui sont pas les mêmes mais il faut le
faire maintenant pour l'ensemble
d'Europe c'est c'est crucial parce qu'on
ne pourra pas avec des budgets publics
financés tout le monde longtemps en
attendant ce qu'il faut faire et
conscient des choses on a un bouclier
tarifaire qui qui est quand même
protecteur pour la majeure partie des
entreprises sur celles qui ne sont pas
éligibles il faut les traiter et ça fait
deux mois qu'on sait que les boulangers
sont très grandes difficultés il faut
des mesures spécifiques pour les
boulangers et pour une partie des
bouchers qui ont des frigos avec des
entrepôts importants avec de la société
il faut des mesures spécifiques pour
cette prise
bien évidemment c'est une évidence et je
pense que ce matin il faut il faut aller
plus loin voilà c'est une évidence on ne
peut pas en plus on parle aujourd'hui de
des populations de la ruralité voilà et
les boulangers sont souvent la dernière
activité commerciale ils font également
de la poste ils font d'autres activités
en même temps on ne peut pas avoir de
discours il faut pendant les mois qui
viennent le temps de secouer les
Allemands il faut aider bien plus qu'il
ne faut les les boulangers